demi lovato who i don't really know who
she is i think she's a singer or an
actress
uh she went on joe rogan's podcast to
describe sex and gender the only thing
that
that we're talking about these days
because the left has taken away
our higher faculties of reason we no
longer debate
important matters or rather eternal
matters or rather higher matters
we're just talking about our loins and
the longings of our loins so demi lovato
says
that she's fluid now she's really fluid
she's no longer
congealed i don't know she's no longer
solid she's fluid and so
she's actually a pan-sexual take a
listen
i'm so fluid now and
a part of the reason why i am so fluid
is because
i was like super closeted off
you mean like sexually fluid yeah
yeah yeah yeah um
anything really so i just what do they
call that like pansexual or something
like that
yeah yeah pansexual that's hilarious
fluid you're fluid
what do you mean fluid well like like
you like girls or boys
oh i like anything really isn't that so
good
she's really open i don't mean to knock
on demi lovato
she's representative of a broader
culture it's it's good to be open it's
bad to be closed
it's good to just have your loins
titillated by anything
and it's bad to have preferences it's
bad to say some things are good
something's bad some things
are right some things are wrong so demi
lovato is sexually attracted to anything
so she's sexually attracted to kids
right
because kids are within the subset of
anything so
and she's fluid and she's open so she's
probably and she's attracted to animals
right
sexually because she's attracted to
anything she's a pansexual she's
attracted to any
she's attracted to my leftist years
tumbler right
it's in the no i guess the leftist
year's tumblr much much less
objectionable than
the kids or the animals no i i bet if i
asked her this right now i said
you're attracted to kids and animals she
said no oh my gosh no what are you
taught you sicko what are you talking
about okay so then you're not
attracted you're not totally fluent some
things are solid
there are some guard reels here you're
not totally open
you're somewhat closed-minded as
you should be it is good to be somewhat
closed-minded
skepticism has utility only when it
leads to conviction
to quote william f buckley jr quoting a
prominent liberal in god and man at yale
some people are so open-minded that
their brains
fall out fluid
open we can't know anything we're just
we're everything man you know it's just
kind of whatever
man i gotta get to new york don't i no
no i don't
i don't think so we we are in a moment
where our culture wants to deny
that we can say anything and
and the right has fallen for this worse
than the left has at least the left
continues to pursue their own political
agenda
they at least continue to exert their
their will if not their reason
but we on the right we've fallen for we
said well we can't look if i say one
thing's good then you might say another
thing is good and that's just values and
preferences man and we can't know
anything for sure and we can't use our
reason
no guys put down the bong
okay recognize that there is such a
thing
as truth goodness justice
beauty we can kind of know these things
and when we can kind of know these
things we can govern ourselves we used
to know that in america
but i don't know maybe we're all
suffering a cultural short-term memory
loss or something maybe we've had
a few too many rips if you enjoyed that
break from disinformation
historical revision and screaming about
the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button so
that you never miss another video
[Music]
[Music]